over the year preceding the
investigation the execution of mr.
khashoggi a number of other human rights
violations have been documented and I've
been denounced there is no way the
leaders of that state including the
conference were not aware of those
violations in fact there is evidence
credible evidence pointing to their
their involvement what needs to be
investigated is the extent to which the
the conference knew or should have known
of what would have happened to mr.
Khashoggi whether it directly or
indirectly incited the killing whether
he acted without due diligence whether
it could have prevented the execution
when it when the mission started and
failed to do so
even the evidence warranting
international investigation criminal
investigation into the responsibility of
the conference it is a logical step for
me to be asking for him to be included
in the sanctions until and unless there
is evidence provided that he was not
involved didn't know should not have
known of the execution
I concluded that the United States may
not have failed in its responsibilities
to to protect and to warm mr. khashoggi
this being said I did raise a couple of
concerns if that seems improbable to me
that intercept originating from mr. when
the crown prince
would not have been analyzed
particularly if they included some
trigger words such as a bullet for
instance I find it hard to believe that
such an intercept would not have been
analyzed at the time it was intercepted
[Music]
that killing that the execution of mr.
khashoggi violated a range of
international law provisions in violated
of course at the prohibition against
arbitrary killing it violated the Vienna
Convention on consular relations it
violated the prohibition against the
extraterritorial use of force in times
of peace in violated the prohibition
against enforced disappearances and it
may have violated the Convention Against
Torture so the circumstances of that
execution in my view make it a
particularly important case for
universal jurisdictions the UN Special
Rapporteur on extrajudicial executions
Agnes calamari released a report today
providing her detailed findings of her
investigation into the murder of Jamal
Ashok gee the report situated the
killing of Jamal keshavjee within the
context of ongoing Saudi repression of
which we've seen a dramatic increase
since Mohammed bin Salman became Crown
Prince in 2017 in the midst of this
massive campaign and crackdown against
dissidents activists and others the
murder of kasha she took place and she
rightly notes that the crown prince
while there isn't direct smoking-gun
evidence of his involvement in the
murder
there is some culpability due to the
fact that he either approved or
tolerated an ongoing campaign against
dissidents and activists in his own
country the report provides a lot of new
information about the nature of the
killing that we didn't know before and
as such it should give some renewed
momentum to the possibility of further
investigations into the matter hopefully
by the UN secretary-general
that's what Human Rights Watch is
calling for but it also should hopefully
provide additional pressure on Saudi
Arabia to provide more transparency into
the trial
of 11 individuals accused of killing
Jamal khashoggi as well as perhaps open
it up to inter
national investigation is calling on
both members of the Human Rights Council
in Geneva as well as the UN Security
Council in the UN secretary-general to
look at all measures for holding Saudi
Arabia accountable for the murder of
Jamal keshavjee and further
investigating the role of top officials
including NBS in to the killing the
Special Rapporteur agonistic al ahmar
noted in her report that one of the
drawbacks was that she did not have full
cooperation from Turkey and she had
hardly any cooperation from Saudi Arabia
into her investigation and that's one of
the reasons why this needs follow-up it
needs more attention and we need to get
to the bottom of the role of top Saudi
leaders in this murder